Speaker 1: So upon her return from her twelve
hour Twitter ban, radical Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green announced she's holding
a press conference in her office.
The press conference was primarily highlighted
by terrible audio where you can barely hear
the people asking the questions and you can
barely hear Marjorie Taylor Green.
We've amped up the audio level so that you
hopefully will be able to hear it.
And this first question goes right to I don't
know how these right wingers get fixated on
bogus talking points that make no sense, but
they do.
And Marjorie Taylor Green is a big proponent
of the hipper, bogus vaccine talking point.
All right.
So let's listen to this one first.
Speaker 6: And the VA CBS News Westerley said
that he got vaccinated, scything this.
A variant is going around and said he's confident
that it's safe and effective.
Two questions.
Have you gotten vaccinated and do you disagree
with Republican
Speaker 4: women while you're your first question
is a violation of my rights.
You see, whatever rights, we don't have to
reveal our medical records and that also involves
our vaccine records.
Speaker 1: So that is a complete and total
lie.
This has been repeated.
Sean Hannity has said it.
Marjorie Taylor Greene has said it a bunch
of times.
A journalist asking a public figure who is
talking about the merits of vaccination is
not a violation of hippo rights.
HIP stipulates how information.
That is held by health care and health care
insurance companies has to be protected from
fraud and theft, it relates to the digital
transmission of such information and it relates
to those entities exclusively.
It has nothing to do with media questions.
It just has nothing to do with it.
When you go into a doctor's office and you're
given something, that's their privacy policy
and how they protect your data and who they
will share data that's governed by HEPA.
When you are a congresswoman who lies about
vaccines and a journalist says, are you vaccinated?
The question doesn't violate anything related
to Hiba.
She's not forced to answer.
She didn't, by the way.
And it's genuinely stunning that I mean, I
know stupid talking points.
Catch on.
This is a really, really stupid talking point.
And I tweeted about this last night saying,
could anybody tell her that hip hop relates
to medical providers and privacy, not journalists
asking public figures questions?
One common reaction was basically, David.
She's been vaccinated, but she wants to give
certain people who follow her the idea that
she hasn't, because that's what a lot of her
whole indignance perspective and approach
is predicated on, the idea that she's opposing
the vaccine and putting her money where her
mouth is or putting her health where her mouth
is, when in reality she's been vaccinated.
Maybe that's the case.
I don't know, maybe she has been vaccinated.
But if you're telling everyone to be skeptical
of the vaccine, it's relevant and completely
appropriate for journalists to say, have you
been vaccinated?
Now, let's continue just a couple other disgusting
moments from this thing.
She was she as in her statement, she said
something about if you're not obese and you're
not over 65, you're not going to die.
So therefore you don't need to be vaccinated.
And someone points out to her skinny people
and kids have also died and she just laughs
dangerous.
Speaker 4: Do you feel any responsibility
for keeping people in Georgia safe?
You know, there are children, skinny people
who have died of the coronavirus.
Do you feel any responsibility to.
Right.
You know what?
I think people's responsibility is their own.
Speaker 1: So this is just continued disgusting
stuff.
I mentioned this when we talked about when
Joe Rogan said a couple of months ago, young
people don't need to get vaccinated.
There's no reason for young people to get
vaccinated.
I'm paraphrasing.
And he said, you know, if you eat a good diet
and you exercise, I have looked and have still
found no study that suggests diet and exercise
makes you less susceptible to the virus in
terms of an infection, which you may then
spread.
Certainly underlying health makes you less
likely to have a serious case.
That's true.
But we live in a society, folks.
And this stuff from Marjorie Taylor Green
is just disgusting.
One last moment, a Marjorie Taylor Green lashed
out at Marie Newman in a trans phobic rant.
Marie Newman is a congressional candidate.
Newman's daughter is transgender.
Newman has talked about how the lack of support
for trans people and trans youth influenced
her running for office.
And here's Marjorie Taylor Green in a trans
phobic rant accomplish
Speaker 4: in the green room and called you
a deeply broken person in hopes that you would
get some help from any response to this.
I think my colleague, Democrat Marie Newman,
that is across the hall from me, should probably
get some help herself, because she's the one
that attacked me on it on a video by planting
a flag out there in the hallway.
But starting on my nameplate, you see, she
started that.
You do understand that, right?
Speaker 1: She started it, guys.
Speaker 4: She started by a video on my nameplate.
And then it pans to her where in a militant
fashion, she plants a flag.
But, you know, and then she talks about her
biological son, who she calls her daughter,
and she talks about one issue.
Speaker 1: And of course, I hope you guys
know when using this phraseology of her son,
who she calls her daughter, which completely
delegitimizes every aspect of of transgender
individuals.
It's just marine human is just calling something
a different name than it actually should be
called.
Right.
It's completely dehumanizing.
Speaker 4: Wants her son to be able to go
in women's bathrooms and have all the same
rights as women that, you know, when I have
daughters, too, and I don't want men in my
daughter's bathroom.
Speaker 1: So just a completely disgusting
bathroom.
Trans phobic bathroom rant from Marjorie Taylor
Green.
Really, truly, genuinely a despicable person.
If she gets reelected and she's she's presumably
going to run, we are really going to have
to concede that this virus of Trump ism is
probably going to be here to stay for some
significant
period of time.